Bob Huber was an important and admired
figure in the field and I'm sorry about
his recent death we'll do our best to
make up for his absence by taking up
some of the ideas that he proposed in
his paper I was originally to have been
a humble lunch guest today but I've been
elevated to participate in this panel
organized around Bob's paper and I'm
very pleased join the other panelists
America engages Eurasia a wonderful
large and noble project you might be
forgiven for thinking that today's
subject funding is not among the most
scintillating themes of your summer
agenda it's a kind of gray subject on
its surface but in fact it's connected
to a very important larger story to be
told about knowledge acquisition and
deployment and about our interactions
with other parts of the world and not
just your Asian let me say right off
that if you've read the hubert vapor
that he's really quite right to point
out that there was something of an over
identification of russian eurasian and
east european studies as a cold more
enterprise or at least i would say that
to see it simply as a cold war
enterprise though partly true was also
an exaggeration a brief personal history
to tell you how my own perspective was
shaped i began as a graduate student in
the Harvard Soviet program in 1952 at
the height of the Cold War and at the
same time i worked at the russian
research center as an assistant on the
air force project on the soviet social
system i completed the PhD in sociology
at harvard and went off to teach at
smith college and then quickly moved to
Princeton where I taught courses on the
Soviet Union trained several PhDs in
sociology specializing in the USSR in
nineteen
68 I became the founding executive
director of I Rex the international
research and exchanges board which was
in charge of this country's principal
scholar exchanges with Eastern Europe
and the Soviet Union and I served there
until nineteen ninety-two during 70s and
80s I oversaw a major expansion of
collaborative activities with social
scientists and humanists in eastern
europe and soviet union after the
collapse of communism i found a new
organization project on ethnic relations
which was involved in inter-ethnic
disputes in eastern europe primarily in
the balkans and i chaired some of the
principal discussions that led to the
compromises between Romanians and their
Hungarian minority and between the
Montenegrins and that country's albanian
minority in Yugoslavia I organized the
first say the last contacts between the
Serbs and the Kosovar Albanians before
the war broke out as well as their first
post-war contacts in Macedonia I chaired
the follow up conferences to the audit
framework agreement that followed the
Albanian insurgency in 2001 so my career
moves in scholarship to organization to
private diplomacy and it coincided with
the rise and fall of a cold war and its
post-communist early aftermath but above
all I was a fundraiser many of us who
were involved in the development and
what used to be called Soviet least
European studies are still suffering
from what I would call post-traumatic
funding syndrome
when I was a graduate student I used to
start to get anxiety dreams about
missing exams something probably that
many of you are familiar with when I
started teaching at the University I
started to have anxiety dreams about
failing to give exams on time but a
couple of years after I took over or
started irex these dreams were replaced
by a nightmare about the disappearance
of funding and in which hundreds of
scholars and staffers were left stranded
when the money ran out and that became
my permanent dream for which I have
never recovered so it's it's kind of fun
today to feel like a dinosaur whose
bones are being excused and by a
latter-day group which is looking back
on some of those experiences in any case
I was a member one of the members of
that relatively small interlocking
Directorate of national and academic
based institutions that were responsible
for the care and feeding of Soviet least
European studies it was an era of very
strong field solidarity is the best way
I can put it there was a kind of
communal national sense which involved
the large research institutions for
example the Columbia is the harbour of
the Illinois is the Berkeley's and so
forth together with the leading academic
organizations such as acls SSRC later on
the Kenan Institute I Rex of course and
we would meet together with some
frequency to plot and plan and compare
notes now it's true that we sometimes
invoke the Cold War know your enemy
theme to enlist public and foundation
support for several enterprises and why
not but this
had more to do I think and this comes
back to the point of view Bob hubris
paper I think in retrospect it had more
to do with the way Outsiders perceived
the purposes of our work than our own
view of it which was focused on the
development of serious scholarship and
expertise rooted in the integrated and
to the extent possible interdisciplinary
and in-depth focus on a region a country
or culture I think I can honestly say
that that really was the priority in our
thinking although the issue of the Cold
War obviously could hardly be considered
a minor one but I cannot tell you how
many times I was called upon to explain
not always successfully to some of my
State Department and the united states
information agency colleagues who
provided a good deal of her exes funding
that the study of literature was no less
important to our understanding of Russia
or Poland or Central Asia then counting
tanks but if I could divert them by
advertising the tank counting instead of
the Pushkin studies even while spending
some of our money on the Pushkin studies
that was okay by me alas the end of the
Cold War accelerated and combined with
the long-standing and in some ways still
unresolved tension between area studies
and academic disciplines especially in
the social sciences area specialists
were and are frequently scorned for not
contributing to the scientific and
generalizing aspirations of the
traditional disciplines and now that the
countries of the former Soviet Union
have finally joined the ranks of
ordinary capitalist or semi capitalist
societies it is perceived that there is
no more need for special area studies
let me be clear that i am a
permanent recidivist concerning area
studies I believe and believe that and
not just with respect to Eurasia but
really with respect to all other world
areas I believed and believe that there
is no substitute for knowledge of a
region or country built around a core of
language and culture and that the
abandonment of area studies following a
cold war has been a serious and
continuing loss although I suspect to
some extent that battle is over in part
because of the general decline in
funding and the fact there is less
latitude for the kinds of things that we
used to do in what have been called area
studies the root problem in my opinion
and here I expose my intellectual
prejudices and perhaps shortcomings the
root problem it seems to me is that the
there is an exaggerated self-regard of
the disciplines particularly in the
social sciences which in fact cannot and
probably do not have not and probably
cannot fulfill their scientific
aspirations as templates for
understanding whole societies and
cultures and whose insecurities only
make them even more intolerant of Neriah
approach there is a kind of anxiety
among people who are leaders in
disciplines to affirm and show their
scientific capacities and one an ass one
side product of this is to insist that
people who are involved in areas that is
really ought to be paying attention
science part of it and not to the area
part of it but it comes I think from a
curiously enough a form of continuing
and probably an inbuilt intellectual and
security about the disappoint as
themselves I have to say that after my I
rights experience
some of this prejudice was confirmed by
what happened to me in the field when I
was with the project on that think
relationships are working with the
testosterone filled people who were
leading these ethnic conflicts it was
confirmed to me that the people who
succeeded in bringing them together or
managing the more understanding them
were people who were or worked with
people who had really very deep internal
knowledge of those societies and that
who understood regional and cultural and
in-country idiosyncrasies and specifics
as compared to the generalizing
contributions from disciplines such as
political science and sociology and
their their illegitimate offspring of
conflict resolution studies they were
always they were always too much and too
late that is to say we ended up well
after the fact knowing more about things
that and and what we knew was not very
useful it was interesting and it was it
was not irrelevant but from the game
from a narrow applied point of view it
it was it was really not very much you
said all the trains had long since left
the station by the time the academics
got to it and what they were writing
basically was was history and what i
would call week generalization said that
is that they were true enough but they
didn't really always tell you what you
needed to know or do in the field so
again my own prejudice is the the
country specific area specific cultural
specific but really in-depth knowledge
is something which is certainly not
absent in the American academic
community but there's not enough of it
and some of the things that get us into
trouble in other parts of the world have
come exactly from that kind of absence
I'll stop here but I want to say that
one of the one of the one of the
resources that kept us on track during
the Cold War and prevented us from doing
worse things than actually haven't had
to do with the people who understood
these societies in depth they were they
were moderating cautioning influence and
and that however much they may have
disagreed among themselves on
interpretation but they were anchored in
those places and made a huge
contribution to our national safety and
well-being and I'm sorry to see the
evaporation of those efforts or the
diminution of those efforts so I'll stop
there and appreciate being able to
present a few dinosaur bones if we are
we self chaired over 90 fault my tivo on
you thank you
hello I'm Nina buoys before I start Alan
began with our sympathy and condolences
for Hubert you may know that ye Liana
Bonner died this weekend today is her
funeral and here I should be in Boston
how it's a great loss let me tell you a
little bit about myself I'm primarily a
translator Russian literature and I've
worked with many foundations that deal
dealt deal with the Soviet Union and the
former Soviet Union space I was the
founding director of the sauros
foundations George Soros enjoys being a
maverick and we were positioned as the
non foundation foundation in fact in our
early days people from Ford Foundation
would meet with me but only far from the
building so we would not be seen
together in case I infected them with
some kind of wild anti bureaucratic
approach which would shake the
foundations of the fort foundation
Empire we spent a lot of time of funding
Soviets who had no other access to their
Western colleagues and counterparts
we're sort of the flip side of what I
Rex was doing at the time though we did
I believe how I wrexham their projects
to occasionally no no there you go word
was on the board but without money oh
well George had no money of the time
so what we did do was one of the
niftiest things that we provided were
travel grants for scholars to actually
present their work at international
conferences the usual set up in the
dinosaur days was that the head of the
department got to go and read that
person's paper the nephew of the head of
the department got to go but not the
scholar because there were no funds in
the department for this person to travel
so we set up a program that gave funds
for that person to go paulus made sure
of exit visa was granted you may not
know about it but there were exit visas
as well as entry visas to the country to
which you were going but you also had to
get a Soviet permission to leave the
country and we would pay for their
tickets and the incredible impact for
these people to meet their colleagues to
be able to have a fairly free
conversation in their field was
astonishing it was very liberating very
undermining of the Soviet system it was
great we felt it was very important and
one of the things that I wonder about
now because I don't have any data on it
it but perhaps you and academia can
actually think about this will be
talking generally in the afternoon is
that setup is have you dealt with your
colleagues from Russia say or Central
Asia how has that impacted your studies
I mean these used to be such closed
firewalled areas where American scholars
did the best that they could without
actual
we talking to their counterparts got to
go on very carefully monitored trips and
perhaps even spend a semester in their
country deepening their knowledge which
is so important because as you know
America as a country is not very
interested in things outside America so
to have Americans go and become expert
in their area was very important I want
to know what happened to Americans who
came in contact with Russians and other
cultures in America who came as a result
of the opening up of these exchanges and
now that as a Hubert or maybe some it
was even who said that let's become
normal country maybe that was Blair he's
not here so we don't have to mention it
how has the interest changed in those
countries now that they're normal and
not as an icee still very interesting to
some people here you are which is I
think a very important aspect of post
Cold War relations so that's one of the
things that I think we could touch upon
and another is how but again it's the
flip side which is how have American
Studies changed in these countries as a
result which is perhaps not in our
discussion today but I would really like
to know what your impressions are of
what's been going on now that there has
been this openness
academics on both sides of this firewall
we at soros found that it was incredibly
invigorating to academic studies to have
this kind of exchange we did it not only
with academics we did it with lawyers we
set up a program with the Bar
Association the American Bar Association
to bring young lawyers to intern we had
an entertainment lawyer from Riga we had
people working in a prosecutor's office
in Florida we had defense attorneys
learning about the jury system these
were things that were new then and
important to the future generations of
lawyers to come so the the seeds that
were planted by organizations not just
foundations of course the more formal
programs are bearing fruit and I would
like to take a little time later to
perhaps talk about it a little eyelid
with the socket of foundation now and
we're still very concerned about whom
the lack of human rights civil rights
that need to be developed further these
are areas that continue to trouble those
of us who it during the Cold War worried
about democratization and peace there's
still a lot to be done and I hope that
everyone here will be working toward
those same goals thank you
alright thank you thanks to the
organizers for the invitation I to all
right so the organizers won't get there
thanks recorded but they know that their
environments I too would like to add a
few words to the memory of Bob Huber he
was a friend and a colleague a powerful
voice in Washington in the American
academic community for for our field he
will certainly be missed a there will be
a memorial service or memorial ceremony
of some kind at the ACS annual meeting
in November yes he certainly it was a
complete shocked to learn his death I'd
also like to follow my predecessors and
say things introducing myself my
academic training was in several
different fields including classical
languages of philosophy but the PhD was
in political science in East European
studies study of the transformations in
1989 in Eastern Europe since then I have
been mostly working at the American
Council of learned societies as now
Director of International Programs i
will say that what you have represented
here our intermediary organizations side
Foundation which is a foundation that
has its own funds the other
organizations represented here are don't
have funds of their own but organized
activities to support various fields
including including this one and that's
there'll be come important as I go on to
talk about the basic subject I want to
say that two of the through the programs
that are most relevant that I run at
ACLs one is been supported by title
eight State Department for East European
studies funding American graduate
students and scholars in language
training and research in countries of
Eastern Europe and their languages the
other one is a very different one it's
an international program that actually
works internationally it was called the
humanities program in Belarus Russia and
Ukraine supported by the Carnegie
Corporation of New York which for 12
years provided research funding to
scholars in those three countries to do
their work there so the idea was to
build the sort of intellectual
infrastructure in those countries help
sustain it and actually in the period in
the last 12 years to encourage scholars
to stay in the field there were so many
attractions distractions clever people
who knew the languages could get could
make a lot more money in the private
sector or by emigrating and we were
trying to to encourage people to
continue their their academic work all
of which is to say that I have become
very interested in comparative academic
cultures and it's interesting to look at
America from other countries and to look
at other countries from the United
States so something that Nina said
Americans are not very interested in
it's absolutely true but we need to ask
compared with what if you compare to the
interest of academic communities in
other countries but the rest of the
world American comes up actually pretty
good and because they're there are
robust studies fields etc sever a to
sort of segue into the main topic that
we're discussing today which is funding
for the field then and now our friend
funding for your Asian Studies and now
I'd like to start by examining a couple
of terms here
funding what does this mean and I think
it's we need to divide funding for basic
research that is direct funding for
direct funding for research that is
scholars getting grants to do them from
something that's not quite so visible
but it is very important and what I want
to stress in my talk today and that is
the development of funding that develops
a infrastructure for scholarly
communication that creates a field and
that's the second term I wanted I want
to to examine or what is fields is it
certainly the people working in it in
the individuals working at their at
their institutions where they have
commitments and responsibilities where
apologies and but it's also their
connections across institutions and it's
that that sort of infrastructure of
communication that that I think is not
only useful but it's actually essential
there can't be a field without that
field isn't that does not consist of
individuals working on a particular
topic it consists those individuals who
have vehicles for communication and I
use the term scholarly communication
it's probably more familiar as a arch
synonym for publications but here it
actually is using it in the natural
language signification that is people
talking to one and other people people
exchanging
exchanging ideas discussing professional
issues sort of intellectually or
organizing their their intellectual
projects and the third term I want to
focus on is Eurasian because I'm going
to talk more about Eastern Europe it's
my me ta it's where I come from where I
studied what I studied and and where I
spent quite a bit of my working working
career in the last 15 years but I think
it's also useful to take this kind of
sideways glance at the topic because we
can talk about what it takes what it
means to be a field what it takes to be
a field and what funding needs to do in
order to sustain the existence of a
field what in the United States fields
of study be their disciplinary fields or
area studies fields are supported
principally by and through as we should
say through learning societies a
learning society is the infrastructure
or provides most of the infrastructure
for scholarly communication and learning
society comes from the it's our middle
name at American Council of learned
societies and it's an old-fashioned term
but I think it's a useful scholarly
organization professional organization
it's a voluntary self-managed
self-financing membership organization
of scholars of all ranks in and out of
academia this purpose it is simplifying
to hold an annual meeting for
presentation and exam
we work to provide opportunities for
discussion of professional matters
including the effectiveness of graduate
training and availability of research
support and to publish a journal record
for the airing of significant research
and intellectual issues related to the
interests of the Society's members tried
to make this a formal definition the
point isn't it we could quibble about it
but I want to say that East European
studies never had such a learned society
and does not have the field of Russian
Soviet post-soviet Eurasian East
European studies does have such as I
learn in society and and I think it's
under appreciated for for the work that
it does for the and for the
opportunities that it provides for
communication people go there because
they want to see old friends but they
don't always appreciate how what it
would be like if it did exist you didn't
have if we didn't have that opportunity
the so let's go back to East European
studies it's a small field it exists
against the background in the shadow of
this archerfield and has always done so
and always will
before and here i will contend a little
bit with what Bob Huber root wrote about
the significance of cold war funding for
the field for the field of East European
studies the cold war funding that was
provided by I delayed specifically it's
absolutely crucial if field would not
exist in this country even in its
limited way without without that funny
before the 1980s I was just stepped out
but he reminded me that that Wow let's
go say before the 1980s there were no
national organizations dedicated
exclusively to East European studies in
this country there was triple a SS but
that was you know with the advent of
time late funding there were three that
appeared one was the the ACLS Joint
Committee and then just the ACS
committees on East European studies and
language training gave out grants year
after year in those grants for 25 years
have been coming and almost everyone and
the field of East European studies has
had some Association either receiving
one of those pants are sitting on the
committee's there was the canada
institute woodrow wilson centers easter
pian studies programs junior scholar
training seminar where
a graduate students would come and
discuss their work and there was the
appearance of the journal easter korean
politics and societies so these three
institutions and serve the function of a
learning society for the field and the
crisis of we have been receiving funding
from title eight have thought of it as
an annual crisis for the last I don't
know decade thinking that this might be
the last year ticklish funding and
somehow it's still here although it's
it's mmm the prospects are growing
increasingly a dimmer and more
restrictive but the what I want to put
before you is the hypothesis that that a
field depends not just about money to do
research but an infrastructure which is
something like a learnin society which
has those learners society functions and
that the crisis for for East European
studies is not only that individuals
would might not have title aid funding
available for them but that the these
the infrastructure of salt scholarly
communication would be severely damaged
the the junior scholars training seminar
would would no longer take place so that
opportunity for graduate students to
become socialized into the field to
begin to get a sense of what you know
how their work fits into the wider wider
picture would would not be there and the
ACLS committees would would also not be
couldn't continue their work and again
the work is certainly first in the first
instance and the first importance is
giving support to individuals to do
their work but and here i want to just
expand talk a little bit about the what
the committee's do because it's a it's a
crucial function in the maintenance and
for the development of a field and that
is the discussion of what counts for
quality at the committee meetings a
National Committee which reads
applications from institutions all
across the country has the best possible
insight into the new work that's being
done new approaches new trends new
topics it is a forum at which those are
critically evaluated are you know and so
the through the decisions of the
committee makes they are able to to have
to comment on what's happening in the
field if that venue is not available if
there isn't such a committee if there
isn't such a competition and I'm and
these are represented here our
organizations which which are in the
business of organizing just such an
international competitions if that's not
there then sure individuals can apply
for other funding they can apply through
their university they could apply
through but they're not applying within
a field which has that kind of oversight
function over what the norms of quality
the
the sort of development of a working
consensus on those norms that scholars
use as they do their own work and then
as they peer review the work of others I
should also mention in this regard East
European politics and societies which is
beginning to take on a larger larger
role in the East European studies
because it's the only national I mean
it's the only self-sustaining national
institution for this very small field so
again a East European studies is an
example of what it means to be a field
it is an example of a struggling field
and it is an example of how important it
is to have this to have venues to have
to have opportunities structured
opportunities for scholars working in
the field to be able to discuss issues
such as norms of quality what the new
trends are and ok so that's the i were
to answer my suppose and answer my own
question about what it takes to maintain
a strong field of studies it is that
this scholarly of infrastructure of
communication thank you I want to echo
Bob's incredibly insightful points about
the historical trends and the
motivations for targeted funding for
your Asian Studies and it's inextricable
history with the Cold War at the same
time I want to think more currently
about our current precarious shall we
say funding environment for European
studies boat or Eurasian studies both at
the level of the University where cuts
are substantial and we're in a quick
survey after the vicious ripping a part
of title six a quick survey of seven of
the the center directors none of them
we're getting any additional funding to
compensate for the decline in title six
funding from their universities none so
universities benefited from having title
six funding all those years this year
we've got a forty seven percent decrease
in that budget not one of the seven
center directors that I was able to
contact is getting a dime additional
from their University to compensate for
this loss again focusing on that idea
that university see this is something if
it's important Washington will write you
a check certainly not coming out of my
department you know my college budget
the second thing about the precarious
nature of this has to do with the
extraordinarily small shall we say
confidence that many of us have in terms
of the future security of title eight
and I think that this is also an
important element of Bob's legacy he
worked tirelessly to really employ as as
employee all forces possible to protect
title eight funding and I wondered i
know i didn't know understand as an
academic that title eight is
extraordinarily small we're talking
about five million dollars which in most
yeah well about i'm hopeful right so
it's a little it's it's a bit under five
million from that you've got to take out
the administrative costs for running the
program and so really in terms of the
money that's given out you're talking it
wasn't at 4.2 this year 4.2 million
dollars the average size of an NSF grant
one NSF grant in sociology is four
hundred and ninety thousand dollars they
give out 80 on average every year so
let's think about and that's just in
sociology that's just one of the
divisions within NSF so we think about
this in balance this targeted funding is
really quite small but it's
extraordinarily precarious and one of
the reasons why i think it is so
precarious and I could be completely
wrong come
at this from it from a different perhaps
generational perspective is that asked
scholars and I put myself in this
category as well I've certainly enjoyed
funding from Soros funny Norma's funding
from I Rex and I'm extremely grateful
and Kenan and SSRC which I founder echt
as scholars we should have been doing as
well as as as administrators from the
other side we should have been doing a
better job on documenting the success of
these funding programs and we have also
done ourselves a disservice by not
advertising and documenting the rigor of
the selection processes the importance
and the quality of the research that is
generated from this these specific
funding lines once that is done i think
it's extraordinarily simple to
communicate to universities and indeed
to your departments that yes getting an
RX is a big deal this is an incredibly
prestigious award yes getting a research
grant from the National Council is
extraordinarily prestigious and look at
the people who are on the selection
committee that yes an SSRC award as a
postdoc is a stamp of academic
excellence and it's not just
disciplinary excellence its area studies
excellence and say it unashamedly and
say it very strongly we haven't done a
good job with that we've been a little
too apologetic I think and at this point
it's extraordinarily important that we
work together both academics as well as
funders to really carefully and
convincingly articulate that this is not
a second class line of funding and that
it's here for a specific reason and it's
here because the demands of becoming an
expert in this part of the world are
higher and you've got to have the
language you've got to have the travel
opportunities you have to have the
networking and if you don't this is a
critical area of the world that we will
simply not know anything about and I
think that's an argument we can make
effectively and I would encourage us all
to really redouble our efforts
to make that both at our department
levels at our universities but indeed
nationally I think that's really
important for my part one of the things
that we did last year at the SSRC is to
take a big view and do a 15 year
retrospective where are our scholars now
and there are four things that the
graduate of the dissertation right up
the wards and the pre dissertation
awards that SSRC is given out your asian
studies really accomplished the first
thing is we could prove with these
grants our students no longer faced a
handicap in completion of the
dissertation on average people who have
some sort of area expertise according to
The Chronicle of Higher Education take
two point two years longer in the social
sciences economics political science and
sociology I really think economics is an
empty cell but that's what they said in
the report if they're doing primary work
in foreign language 2.2 years longer
when I looked from 1995 up until 2011
with SSRC there was no statistically
significant difference between the
graduation time of our recipients and
their non area studies colleagues
that's easy enough to measure that's
something that made title eight sit back
and really think while we're really
effective but unless we gather that
information and unless we convey it in a
convincing fashion where we're in bad
shape so we really need to look at what
happens in terms of completion time the
second thing we need to think about is
what happens in terms of commitment to
the field ninety percent of our
dissertation right up award winners in
the past 20 years still work in Eurasia
as their primary focus that says a lot
people's interest change change and that
can be a wonderful and inventive and
exciting thing but to have ninety
percent still stay in the area is pretty
impressive now granted some of them have
just recently finished so it's hard to
say what will happen in the long term
but we're really working on retaining
scholars in the field and that's
important the third thing that I think
we need to focus on a little bit more is
that often times these sorts of focused
funding translate into larger academic
processes and projects that gain either
wider institutional support funding from
the Carnegie Corporation the Ford
Foundation the National Science
Foundation or the National Institutes of
Health and so they can be seen as a step
in a scholarly process how many NC er
grants which tend to be fairly modest in
size actually have translated into later
grants from other national funding
organizations or later projects that
major foundations have seen fit to fund
we haven't done a enough work I think in
terms of really documenting and
carefully articulating how successful
our funding has been and the fourth
element I think that we can do a better
job on is really articulating in a very
very adamant fashion a
reconceptualization of this fabulous
term that everyone
takes to heart policy relevance having
just run a workshop with great thanks to
2 to Blair in the Kenan in in DC with
our fellows I thought it was a great
time to invite some folks from the State
Department over to see the fellows
present their work these are really
terrific graduate students from six
different disciplines who are doing all
sorts of fascinating work and I'm like
okay State Department's coming they're
going to want to talk to the guy who
works I'm Chechen refugees right they're
going to want to talk to a woman who's
doing political economy in Eastern
Europe they're going to want this that I
send them a list as always happens of
course they said they're going to show
up at a certain time and then they're
not there right so they come for the
verrat medical or know the your birdie
on linguistic anthropologists which I
thought was going to be a you know just
a home run there was no question they
came in and she's talking about code
switching she's talking about how
Bharat's negotiate the use of her yacht
language and Russian language in
everyday life and in what spheres they
use what words and how this comes up and
she's deconstructing jokes basically
throughout her talk fabulous scholar
from the University of Michigan I was
astounded that representatives from the
State Department's were were completely
hook line and sinker in they were
fascinated they were able to link this
together and talk during the coffee
break about what this means about
identity about the importance of
multiculturalism in the Russian
Federation about all the things that I
think the people around this table would
hope they would find as important and so
what was really for me the take-home
point and the thing that I wanted to
share with the fellows during this
workshop is that bombs and rockets
aren't always policy relevance and that
we can be as opposed to being apologetic
and saying well if we do a little bombs
and rockets then we can have a couple
linguistic anthropologists run around in
the provinces I think what we need to be
able and again this is a difficult
conversation but we need to be able to
convincingly articulate to our academic
communities to our institutional
communities at the university level but
more importantly to national funders
that knowledge of a region with the
geopolitical significance of Eurasia is
policy-relevant and that knowledge may
take form take the form of linguistic
analysis that may take the form of
literary analysis it may be couched in
15th century history but to take a
broader idea about knowledge just as now
Secretary Clinton is pushing the State
Department to take a broader look at
power we can be part of that
conversation in your asian studies we
have the legacy we were privileged
during the Cold War that privilege it is
gone now but I still think we have a
case to make in terms of showing why
this funding is important why it is a
value to the Academy and more
importantly why it is a value to
national interests thanks very much well
I apologize for being late was foolish
of me to rely on the dependability of
American public transportation of 5 15
min them in the morning but I'm here and
I'm here really I don't want to be
anyplace else there are many reasons for
that edward has i don't think i've ever
said this about edward but Alan I know
had his own relationship with George
Kennan a George could be a kind of
prickly guy and it would be this moment
when we would argue about what we should
be doing and I discovered one one time
trying
to find some subject to talk to George
candid about that wouldn't be an
argument about how I was ruining his
namesake institution we started talking
about new york public library in about
edward and turns that Edward was a euro
for George Kennan and so to be
associated with anything that's
associated with Edward is an honor I
looked at the table I see Alan casts off
who's as instrumental for my career is
anybody and I got the grants because
Alan secured the money and and ran an
organization that was really serious
about the field that was once Soviet
nice european studies I'll say a little
bit about what it is but finally Bob
Huber was my closest friend and
colleague in the field and cindy's at SS
or see I was at SRC a nabob followed me
and we fought many of the same battles
we're talking about here and to have an
opportunity to comment on the start off
with Bob's paper and to think that he's
still around basically it was really an
honor when I was walking up the subway
steps outside the gate I realized I
hadn't really thought about this but
forty two summers ago I started learning
Russian here I was on your graduate of
the University of North Carolina but I
was from New York I wanted to learn
Russian so I was walking up those steps
to learn Russian and then I walk in I
don't think megan is still here if I met
Megan dancers she met me and we started
talking about what she's doing and her
interest in Polish Ukrainian Russian
cultural relations and kind of the
juxtaposition made me realize only how
different the world is but how different
the intellectual enterprise of studying
this region has become and I yeah you
all have my remarks I'm going to make
some of the same points but I want to do
it in a slightly different way I take
the point of normalization of this
feel very seriously but normalization as
exciting as it is intellectually means
people don't care what we do people
aren't going to fund us people don't
care what happens in French studies they
really don't care what happens in German
Studies you all are attracted to this
region for the reasons people are
attracted to studying Latin America or
Asian societies because it's a complex
region which seems to contain within it
both questions and perhaps some answers
to the to the nature of the human
condition when I entered the field why
was coming here 42 years ago there were
other motivations for studying this
region the Soviet Union was enemy number
one Russia is not enemy number one for
the United States there was national
security who's the whole policy relevant
debate I I do want to say about your
meeting at the State Department Cindy
you shouldn't have been surprised who
are those analysts they're probably
ollies many PhDs agree on that tables
there are around this table they're
frustrated academics and part of what i
want to say is i want to talk about how
feels or conversations and we shouldn't
assume that because somebody sits in the
state department that they're not part
of the same conversation we're actually
on the same side of the barricades
against their sort of bosses and i think
that that really is important and the
problem is one of the ways in which the
Soviet studies field was different
despite all the heroic efforts of Alan
and others to ensure that this wasn't
the case this was a highly politicized
field because national security was
escaped so I don't lament the passing of
the old days I'm going to say something
about funding in a moment but I really
do think this is a healthier feel a more
normal feel now Andre was absolutely
right when I came in he was talking
about the importance of funding and
organizational structure
there's four fields and there's no doubt
that that's important but it does seem
to me that an academic field is first
and foremost a conversation and when we
think about Soviet studies and even
Russian studies it has it to some extent
East European studies I get to draw a
distinction in a moment this has been a
very truncated conversation 42 years ago
when I was coming here it was truncated
and that we didn't really interact with
our Soviet in these European colleagues
the American Enterprise of studying
Eastern Europe in the Soviet Union was a
self-contained world in which Americans
what we talked to European some time to
time particularly the Brits maybe the
Germans but not really because nobody
bothered to learn German and certainly
no one read anything in French but we
basically talked to ourselves so it was
a truncated conversation then I think
it's a truncated conversation and a very
different way now and I think it's a
generational divide I think people who
enter the field after the collapse of
the Soviet Union really don't feel as if
they have to go back and read anything
that happened they're all christopher
columbus's and therefore when you pick
up books about subject x in our field
there are rarely conversations with the
work that came before there's a very
recent paper that Bob Huber sent me
probably last paper the National Council
put out under his guidance and it was on
subject they do something about politics
of Leningrad there's not one reference
to any work in that paper by anybody who
wrote on about that city before the
author entered graduate school but this
isn't unusual so that's the second way
in which it's a truncated conversation
and the third way of course and i gather
ellen has already talked about this is
we've lost the area studies discipline
debate it's over it's a tragedy I think
it's a tragedy for the United State
that we don't value area knowledge not
because of Russian studies but because
in the Middle East because we have young
Americans walking down streets not
understanding what's going on around
them and nobody around to tell them
what's going on around them and getting
killed that's the tragedy but that
battle was lost long ago we are now
whatever we do Cindy said it you have to
learn statistical methods and the local
culture people have to be engaged in the
discipline and this has led to another
normalization of the field like Latin
American Studies like I'm thinking year
while African Studies a different parts
of studies of Asian societies there no
economist who study the Russian economy
is this distinctive feel the reason Alan
remembers this one of the first missions
a title eight was to support economists
they all went off the World Bank and
became economist's they couldn't get
jobs and universities but they're
they're actually probably doing much
more important things political the
study of Russian politics is through a
disciplinary paradigm for better or for
worse so the field becomes like latin
american studies are african studies a
field in which the kind of contextual
knowledge that we're interested in
becomes part of the discipline history
literature sociology anthropology
particularly anthropology there's a
really exciting emergence of
anthropology over the past 15 years and
in this region so i want to say that
basically this normalization is good
news it's helped us advance the
conversation but i would do want to add
a couple of caveats cindy makes a very
good point that
more money at one level is better but
another level it isn't it creates
dependency this is a field that
luxurious and funded Andre is right we
have had an annual title a crisis every
year for the past 15 years but that's
the good news there's a crisis to have
and thus far we've all we carry the day
in large part because of Bob but because
of many people so I think one of the
ways in which it wasn't a normal
conversation is that it really was give
it was a gilded conversation that was
pushed in certain directions because of
monies it doesn't exist in other fields
a second way is when you think about
French studies or african studies or
Japanese studies or korean studies the
preponderance of work in those fields
doesn't take place here it takes place
in those societies who's most interested
in French history the French who's most
interested in Japanese history the
Japanese because of the Soviet overhang
the study of the social sciences in the
region we study has many many battles
that are still being fought and that has
made for a truncated conversation it's
still we all have wonderful Russian
colleagues and Ukrainian colleagues it's
a little bit easier in Eastern Europe
and in this way I think Eastern Europe
is kind of past the barrier but it's
still very very difficult to engage
Russian academia writ large we have
individual colleagues now but we still
don't have the institutional linkages
and I think that affects the
conversation of ways it does make us
different another way is who funds
Japanese studies the Japanese society
for the motion of science the Japan
Foundation
the goethe-institut studies supports
german studies up until recently the
Russians haven't studied having
supported Russian studies now there's
Russian world or trying but they really
lots of issues I think these Europeans
may have been a little bit further ahead
in this again this is a way which East
European studies is different but they
don't have a lot of resources so I think
that that's another way in which the
natural conversation is truncated and
leaves the study of this region in a
very awkward position and finally
there's the reaction of and here i think
the further east you go the stronger
this reaction is what i was just at our
conference on higher education in the
region of vilnius and there was a big
angry discussion among polish scholars
about the same issue there is with the
right with the challenge of nation
building and the rise of battles over
national identity there are lots of
scholars and public intellectuals in the
region who really could care less what
we have to say about their history and
their societies they're engaged in a
conversation among themselves so I think
we we have moved and we've normalized in
a certain way we should be proud of that
it's exactly what Edward and Bob Huber
and Alan and many many other people
wanted to see happen and yet it's a very
difficult transition that's not helped
at all by the world around us it's not
helped by the fact that we live in a
country that really doesn't care much
about the outside world unless we think
that they can kill us and nobody's
worried about Russians killing us that
should they can still deliberate the
country in 30 minutes but nobody thinks
about that we live in a country which is
rapidly defunding anything to do
electoral life this leaves us in a very
challenging position as particularly
challenging for a field they had this
elaborate infrastructure that was built
up with money but we really should I
think step back and look at the new
technologies I anybody's on Facebook
Russians Ukrainians are all over
Facebook you know literally we can
engage at least with individual Russian
scholars in a real-time way which we
could in the past one of my closest
colleagues and Urban Studies is in
Yekaterinburg that would have been
unthinkable 42 years ago when I was
trying to learn Russian this is the good
news and finally I think we you all know
this because you are interested enough
and intrigued enough to come spend your
summer here but this is a region which
poses really challenging questions about
what it means to be a human being in the
21st century and we shouldn't lose sight
of the fact despite all the challenges
we have and all the difficulties
convincing somebody on the eighth floor
of the State Department let alone in
Congress that were policy-relevant we
really have the family interests of
questions we can explore so I want to
say that the challenge is yes to keep
funding going but the purpose of that
funding isn't just to support the cannon
institute of the SSRC your acls or I
rugs or the National Nelson the purpose
is to expand the conversation about this
region so that it begins to really
complete the cycle of becoming normal
and we need to recognize it as it does
so it's going to become smaller and a
little bit more challenging and
materially and so on and so forth but
there really are great opportunities
he's out there and again i think megan
is left but what she was talking about
her interest in Russian Ukrainian polish
cultural relations I was thinking how
exciting that must be to be entering the
field where you can wrestle with those
westerns and not a write dissertation
about Soviet trade unions which is what
I do or a book about Leningrad shaping a
Soviet city that came out just as it was
no longer one in grad an old and so so I
think when we think about the field we
should think about those opportunities
as well as the other challenges